Hello Freak bitches for,
but even if we did,
it's worth repeating.
I talked about an article,
an article that was done
by some colleagues of mine,
I don't know them well,
but some,
some academics where they looked at the,
uh,
political affiliation
of professors at top,
I think it was California in schools,
whether they identified it or whether
they actually had democratic affiliation
or Republican.
And as you might imagine,
it was extraordinarily
skewed towards Democrats,
but then depending on the field of study,
so for example,
in sociology and in the
humanities and in women's studies,
women with a y,
by the way,
please don't write women with an e.
That would be sexist at even,
as I said,
the women's oftentimes
and women's studies,
they,
they think that to have men as part
of the word women is itself a form of
aggression.
So they've altered the
spelling to with men.
Oh no,
that's not real.
So you see,
I know your audience already has the price
of admission covered with that story,
but it's still the word women,
right?
So anyway,
so the same word,
why do you have to change the letters?
So in sociology,
do you train,
change the word trigger because it
sounds like the n word or a right,
you're getting triggered.
I'm triggered,
I'm triggered.
Well,
I'm fucking triggered.
If I was black,
I'd be super triggered,
but I don't know if you
notice some of my tweets now,
whenever I tweet anything,
I put a trigger warning trigger warning.
It's not become part of the vernacular
to make it sit there vertical.
It's too close to the n word.
Way Too close.
I am triggered.
But anyways,
to to finish the point
about that study 44 to one,
the ratio in sociology.
So imagine if you are a student
doing an Undergrad in sociology,
right?
It's not a very good thing to have.
Almost all of the professors that you
will ever come across be of one particular
persuasion.
Now,
some people would write to me and say,
but what do you mean?
The Democrats have everything,
right?
They have truth on their side and
the Republicans are a bunch of hacks.
Now when it comes to evolution evolution,
that's true,
right?
If,
if,
if on average republicans are more likely
to deny evolution than that point is
well taken,
but when it comes to issues,
is the death penalty,
right or wrong?
What's kind of fiscal
policy should you have?
What type of foreign
This is not a one plus
one scientific equation,
so you should be exposed
to multiple viewpoints,
but of course you shouldn't be because
you should only interact with people who
are similar to you will that,
that is a problem with a lot
of people that go to college,
graduate,
get their phd,
get their doctorate,
and then start teaching and
never enter the real world,
right?
They stay in this sort of insulated
world of academia and then they espouse
these same ideas.
They promote these same idea.
They promote the same way of thinking as
if this is the real world because this
is the only world they know.
True.
So my friend,
uh,
luther reigns,
he ended up,
he had a massive stroke and
now he's actually for somehow.
So when,
when you have withdrawals
from painkillers,
it feels like you're going to die.
And so when he had the stroke,
they said,
get his mother here,
he's not gonna make it through this.
And we can pump them full on full of
enough drugs for him to get through this.
He's gonna.
He's probably not going to make it.
Somehow miraculously the part of the,
uh,
the brain that is like 30 percent of
his brain got killed during the stroke.
Part of the brain that got killed was
the part that was responsible for feeling
withdrawals.
So somehow he fucking dodged a bullet.
We called the bulletproof bad boy.
I'm somehow he bullet,
he's alive.
He has no more hangovers.
He's completely sober and he goes around
and talks to kids and churches and
things like that.
So he's doing great work.
So he lost 30 percent of his brain.
Yeah.
But somehow he's still a cognitive.
He's still,
you know,
he's still there.
He's jacked.
I mean,
still.
So he's on steroids.
Yeah,
she's fucking Christ.
Might be to be on something.
Yeah.
So he's off the pain pills on
steroids and helping out kids.
Yeah.
There you go.
What the fuck out of a world we live in.
I love that one day we
were eating with them,
uh,
that we're grabbing a burger
or something and he's,
he's got this fanny pack on.
He's like pulling stuff out.
He's trying to find his money,
you know,
he's like,
oh,
I'll pay for it bro.
And he's like moving in slow motion.
He's fucking drooling.
I'm like,
this guy's amazing.
What is going on with this guy?
He's putting all these like
different bottles of pills,
like on the table,
he's got like Viagra and a bunch of
other shit and carries a bottle with him.
Yeah.
And then he put like his fanny pack.
Well there's Bob tools,
the many bottles and then he
puts down like a little bag,
like a clear bag of
something and he's like,
he looks at it and he grabs money clip
and he puts his money on the table and it
looks at the clear baggies like,
whoops.
And he puts that back,
whatever the fuck that was.
That was like,
that wasn't okay for
him to put on the table.
Everything else was fine for some reason.
He's like,
oops,
big old stack of cash.
That's so crazy.
Oh my God,
I was like,
dude,
what if you get your pills mixed up like
you're just running a ton of fucking
Viagra and shit like that,
but we have to be weird that when,
when people are taking these powerful
mind altering substances which can have
these wonderful things as
you and I have experienced,
we got to be aware that there are people
who are not as stable as they think
they are.
People who have deep seeded shit going
on and they don't know what's buried
that's going to come flying out
people or don't understand that yet.
If you're going to jump
jump from the first floor,
not the fifth floor,
so we got to make sure because
the jump from the first floor,
the ground floor,
the ground.
Exactly.
You know,
but that it's going to
be so key because I mean,
look,
just to shift away from
the sales for a second,
one of the issues we're working on big
time is trying to reduce the number of
people dying from overdoses involving
either heroin or pharmaceutical opiates.
For the last couple of years,
more people have died of an accidental
overdose involving heroin or other
pharmaceuticals.
They had a car accident is the number
one cause of accidental death in America
today.
I mean,
it's absolutely crazy stuff.
Right?
And in fact,
when we say overdoses
suggests you took too much.
Most of what our overdose is
actually or drug combinations.
They're typically doing this.
Opiate,
pharmaceutical,
opiate,
oxy Kodo,
and whatever it might be
might be prescribed to you
with booze or with Benzos,
valium type trucks.
Right?
So what we're trying to do is to put out
there the notion that don't care if you
do it.
Opiates,
don't combine it with booze.
Don't combine it with tranquilizers.
There's a miracle drug called the locks
up and we're trying to make that stuff
as widely available.
Reverses the.
It's like an antidote for an overdose.
Make it available.
We're passing nine slash
11 good Samaritan laws.
So if people are around and
a buddy there's overdoses,
they don't just flip out.
They call nine slash 11 right away.
The way it was a heart attack.
So you know,
it's true with the
psychedelics and marijuana,
but even with the drugs that we see as
less elevated in a way with that huge
numbers of people are using life,
the opiates.
It's really important that we become more
and more of a society that understands
the notion that we need to make
it safer to use these drugs.
Right?
We got to keep people from getting
hurt the way that people get hurt.